when trying to understand why we might
be feeling unhappy we tend to be drawn
to reasons relatively close to home it
might have to do with friends
relationships Health jobs families or
schedules what we tend not to do however
is to start talking about our place in
history it would sound overblown or just
plain bizarre to begin to pin a sizable
of our difficulties to Broad historical
forces yet whatever role our psyches and
our families and colleagues might be
playing in our moods a proper
understanding of our situation cannot be
complete without consideration of the
highly peculiar novel era in which we
exist we are troubled in part because we
dwell in highly unbalanced
times at the center of all pre premodern
societies were powers that helped to put
humans in their place older bigger
stronger Holier phenomena perhaps a god
a natural energy or a spirit however
important humans might have felt however
Grand the aristocracy or urgent the news
of the day people knew that they were
not the measure of all things that above
and beyond the Earthly realm there was
something else more mysterious imposing
and strange to which they would all
regularly have to bow and which would
relativize them in one another's eyes
the fanciest King was nothing next to a
thunderous God the mightiest invention
pathetic next to an angry sea but we
humans are now the most astonishing
things we can conceive of it's our
momentous doings our intelligence our
incomprehensibly wondrous technologies
that Mesmerize us and are at the center
of collective consciousness God has died
and nature is to be pied and patronized
like a wounded once proud animal we have
lost any redeeming sense of our own
unimportance we are at the same time
each one of us told repeatedly that we
could do and be anything we might with
sufficient hard work assume the
presidency unlock a major scientific
secret or become known to the entire
planet through our athletic or artistic
prowess
we are also thereby subtly informed that
only a very special Destiny is valid
there is no dignity left in a so-called
ordinary life there can be nothing to
celebrate in an unheralded unknown
existence we cannot live quietly and be
in bed by nine we must become someone or
else look on with envy and rage at those
who have evaded The Perils of mediocrity
we used to know almost nothing of what
happened beyond our own Valley or
Shoreline life went by so slowly that we
were often without appreciating how much
this kept us sane a bit bored now no
Bloodshed Scandal upset or Peril can
occur anywhere on the planet without us
hearing of it in minutes and we are as a
result in a state of continuous unrest
and alarm unable to set anything
negative in context unsure of how to
evaluate our species terrified to trust
or speak to a stranger constantly
feeling that we are leading the wrong
lives we know everything except the less
perceptible things that really matter
our attention is drawn only to our
discords our spitefulness and our
cruelty we've been stripped of
opportunities to contemplate older
slower currents to draw inspiration from
dawn the murmurings of doves or Robins
or the barks of ancient trees that speak
of time measured in centuries we've been
sold the idea that the one solution to
our loneliness lies in romantic love we
therefore search with frantic abandon in
the lonely concrete Canyons of our
modern megalopolises for one very
special being who can be everything to
us best friend sexual partner Playmate
kindergarten teacher cook chauffeur and
then when inevitably we cannot find them
we perceive ourselves as having been
uniquely cursed we misunderstand the
generality of the problem and miss the
Solace available in the less febrile and
less prestigious realm of friendship in
distributing our needs more equitably
among a whole Community none of whose
members need to answer to the whole of
anyone's longings we have been rendered
exceptionally Lonely by the unwittingly
cruel notion of a soulmate we could back
then stand away from our work can see
something substantial and solid that we
had made a chair some horseshoes a house
we now occupy ourselves on tasks that
have been infinitely subdivided and
thereby lost much of their wider logic
we carry professional titles like
Logistics controller automation
Specialist or human resource manager
that show us up as minute cogs in
endlessly complicated engines we may be
richer than ever we struggle to see what
difference we could possibly make to
anyone else's life all the while we lose
ourselves in Temptations which our
revolutionary past leaves us defenseless
against because we were programmed to
eat any sugary thing a rare Blackberry
or apricot that came our way we now
cannot resist the plethora of satanic
Confections on offer on every street
corner because in our old villages we
might have seen one or two fertile
people a day we now can't stop looking
at ceaseless digital processions of the
unclothed we have no willpower to resist
the pitiless Delights of the modern
world it's hard to reverse any of the
pressures we've been placed under but
even if we cannot knowing that these
exist helps us to locate with greater
fairness the origins of many of our
troubles we are not uniquely or
personally awful frantic greedy or
degenerate we are under historically
exceptional pressures to know ourselves
properly is to honor how much of our
Madness does not belong simply to
us